[Applause] and the defenseman for the Blackhawks
control Phillips feeds Bard out to Center Conor
Bard tracked by Robert Thomas Bard shoots wide
to the stick side of Bennington Kev plays the
rebound for Bard down low Bard thecross style
scores unbelievable Conor Bard oh my goodness
on the back head holy jumping he scooped that
up like a lacrosse player reversed it in as a
right hand shot and tucked it by the glove of
the goal tender Bennington oh my dude that was
insane from behind here after a good Rush anyway
we have not seen him do that in a game situation
just yet but the kids got some marvelous hands
there's the wrist shot play goes behind the net
takes it off the boards protects it and he knew
exactly what he was going to do right away I
tell you what I like the rush before that even
going through the neutral zone and uh and got
a good wrist shot that just went wide but that
is a thing of beauty starts off the rush then
he finds himself down behind the net watch this
a little scoop top shelf on Jordan Bennington
no chance at all for the blues net minders
Conor Bard wow otherworldly skill here as he
just softly picks that up on his stick goes up
over the shoulder to equalize this one at one